serverless computing it's a misnomer
used to describe servers in the cloud
that requires zero configuration or
maintenance from the developer
imagine you need water for your house
you could spend a bunch of time and
money digging a well
testing the water quality and plumbing
it to your house or you could just tap
into the city water supply
and pay a monthly fee based on the
amount of water that you use
serverless computing is the same idea
but instead of water
we're talking about the amount of cpu
and memory it takes to run your code
services like aws lambda google cloud
functions and
azure functions allow you to run your
back-end code across their global data
centers
then they mail you a bill at the end of
the month that's factored down to the
millisecond
the beauty of this approach is that your
only concern is writing code
you don't have to pick an operating
system configure networking patch
improvements or provision capacity to
run at scale the cloud handles all that
for you behind the scenes
from an architectural standpoint it
allows you to develop and test each
business requirement
independent of a bigger monolithic
system not only do serverless functions
make servers easier to manage
but they can also be executed based on
different events that happen in the
cloud
which can actually simplify your backend
code for example
you might create a new database record
when a user places an order which then
triggers a serverless function to
send an email confirmation or maybe an
iot event on a home security system
invokes a function that sends a push
notification to the user's device
one of the easiest ways to get started
with serverless is firebase cloud
functions the command line tool will
give us a project
that looks like any other node.js
backend in the code we can export named
functions
that are configured to run on different
events that happen in google cloud
an event could be a simple http request
or a file upload database write
analytics event and so on after writing
our code we can then deploy it to
production with a single command and we
now have a reliable backend that is
ready to scale
this has been serverless in 100 seconds
but if that sounded too good to be true
make sure to stay tuned because i've
invited dane from the filled stacks
youtube channel to show us how to build
a serverless backend for a big complex
project
if you're building anything with
firebase or flutter you'll definitely
want to follow his work
hey there my name is dane and i run a
little youtube channel called
falstax that's focused on sharing the
code that we use to build
apps for our clients over on my channel
we are building a product called
boxed out a set of software built for a
company that wants to run a
product or food delivery service
building one cloud function
is easy but how do you structure dozens
of functions to scale to real world
demands how do you ensure you have a
structured and maintainable
backend how does a back-end with only
serverless functions look
over the next 15 minutes you'll learn
how to build a serverless backend for
non-trivial apps
i'd like to start out by taking you
through a high-level overview of how the
back-end will be set up
this overview will go over the types of
functions we use
as well as the actual code structure the
backend is bold around the strings that
firebase possess
in the serverless cloud functions setup
focusing on those strings
we can break the system into two types
of functions
the two types of functions are restful
and reactive
a reactive function is a function that
will only run
in reaction to data or state that's
being updated on the back end
an example of this will be when a file
is uploaded to cloud storage
or the most common when a document or an
entry in the database has been updated a
restful function is a traditional
restful function which will run when a
client makes an http request
to the uri that the function is assigned
to now we can move on to
the code structure we have an enforced
code structure
that will help with organization of the
backend as well as the overall
maintenance as it grows
there's three major things to go over
number one each function will be
in its own dedicated file this is to get
rid of the natural
tendency when starting with firebase
cloud functions
to keep adding functions into the same
index file forcing it to grow bigger as
your backend requirements grow
and as a note the file name will be the
exact name
of the endpoint or function to keep
things easy to manage
this is not a requirement but i found it
to be quite useful
number two functions will be placed in a
folder titled either restful or reactive
number three the backend will be split
into different resource groups to ensure
a structured backend in production
as a quick example of this we can look
at the code structure below for the
product delivery service backend
there are three resource groups orders
payments
and users and in each of those resource
groups we are very active
and a restful folder this is the only
folder structure that you would need
the rest is handled by the fact that
each of the files will be
its own function now that you have a
basic overview of the code setup
let's start with the actual
implementation
we'll start by creating a new folder
called boxed out
and inside that folder create a new
folder called backend
then we can navigate into the backend
folder and run firebase
init then you have to select yes to
proceed when presented with the
functions to select
we'll choose firestore functions and
emulators
then we'll choose to create a new
project and we'll call out
boxed out dash backend we'll use that
same name for the project
name and then the firestore setup
usually fails on first try because you
have to click on the get
started button go to the url that has
been handed to you
you end up on the cloud firestore page
where you can click on create
database for now we'll start in test
mode i'm going to select
europe west because i'm in africa and
once that is complete
go back to your command line shell that
you've been using
then we can run firebase init again
we'll select firestore functions
and emulators and this time we'll use an
existing
project and we'll use the boxed out
backend that we just created then we'll
select the default
values for all the questions and for the
functions
setup will be using typescript i'm going
to say no to eslint for now
and then i will say yes to installing
the dependencies
when asked about the emulators we will
select functions and firestore press
enter to select
all the default ports and we'll
select to enable the emulator ui if you
don't have the emulators downloaded
select yes to download the emulators
and that should complete your firebase
functions
setup and if we open up this code now
you'll see a folder with another folder
inside called functions
and that is where the end will be
written the files in
the root folder describes the firestore
project and some of the overall rules in
the firestore project
now that we've configured the basics of
firebase functions project
we can implement the backend system as
described
at the beginning we'll start off by
installing the package
dedicated to using the system described
earlier
it's called firebase backend we'll
navigate into the functions folder
and then we'll run npm install firebase
dash
backend then you can open up your
index.ts file
in your source folder you can delete all
of the code in the file currently
then we'll import the function parser
from the firebase backend
then we can set the exports equal to
a newly constructed function parser
that takes in the current directory name
as well as the exports this will be all
the code you need in your index.ts file
regardless of how big your backend gets
and that's also all the setup we need
before we can actually start
writing any functions let's start with
something familiar
we'll create a restful endpoint on our
backend we'll start by creating a folder
the resource group and we'll call that
users
then in the folder we'll create another
folder called
restful and in that folder we'll create
a new file
called add paymentmethod.endpoint.ts
for any endpoint the file has to end in
dot
endpoint dot ts if it doesn't then it
won't be loaded as an http endpoint on
the backend
then we'll start off in the file by
importing request
and response from express and will also
import
endpoint and request type from the
firebase backend
then we will export a default new
endpoint the first value will pass in is
the name
of the endpoint we'll pass in the add
payment method
string the second parameter expects the
type of
endpoint that we are creating we'll pass
in request
type dot post and for the last parameter
we pass in the express endpoint handler
which is will be the actual code that's
executed when your endpoint is called
this is a function that takes in a
request
as well as a response and what we'll
write in this function
is just some code to read the values
sent in the request and then return that
in a different
format so we can know that it's working
we'll start by reading
out the card number and the card holder
from the request
body then we'll create a new value
called payment
token that has these two values
concatenated with an underscore in the
middle and then we'll return
a response with a status 201 and we'll
send back
a map with a key token and we'll assign
it the payment token to make maintenance
easy as the code base grows
remember the tip that i mentioned give
your file name the same name
as your function endpoint that way when
you are debugging an error in production
you know exactly which file to go to to
find your function
now we can go ahead and test out this
function to test this out we can simply
run
npm run serve this will build the
typescript
code and then serve the functions
locally through the emulator
if this command is successful you should
see
the following in your console as you can
see
the api has been deployed under
this url which ends in users dash
api each resource group that you create
will have all the api endpoints under
the resource group
dash api with this deployed let's see if
we can make a post to it and get the
expected
response for this i will be using
postman
we'll take the url that the api has been
deployed to
and paste that in the postman url field
we can add our actual
endpoint name at the end of it slash add
payment method we'll change the request
type to post and then for the body we
will pass in
payroll jason blob the first value will
be
card number i'll give it a basic value
of one two three four five
six seven and the second value will be
card underscore holder and for the value
we'll pass in
full stacks when i execute this function
now we should get back a token
that has the card number followed by
underscore and then with a card holder
at the end of it
and that's it that's how we create an
endpoint and that's how all endpoints
going forward will be created
then you can stop your emulators from
running and will move on to creating a
reactive
function to demonstrate this we'll add a
function that will fire when a new user
is created in the firestore database
we'll create a new folder in the users
folder called reactive and inside that
folder
will create a new file called on
usercreated.function.ts
and as you can imagine the
part.function.ts
is very important that's how we know
which file to load as a reactive cloud
function we'll start off by importing
the firebase functions as
functions and then on the exports we'll
create a new
function called on user created and
we'll assign that
to the oncreate function callback
provided by a document from firestore
to access that we'll index into
functions
go to firestore then supply the document
pattern
that we would like to listen to in our
case we want to listen to the users
collection
and check for any new user id and lastly
we want to listen
to the oncreate function callback this
takes in
a callback function that provides us
with the user's
snapshot as well as the context of this
event trigger
the data for this document can be
retrieved by calling the data function
on the user snapshot
to avoid getting off topic we're simply
going to
log out some text that says that we have
sent an email to
the email value on the data from the
document to test out a reactive
function you have to start all of the
emulators
so the npm run sir function won't work
because that only deploys
the functions to the emulator so to run
this time we'll first run
npm run bold and once that's complete
we'll run
firebase emulators colon start this will
start up
the functions as well as the firestore
emulator that we selected at the
beginning
and then you'll see two urls one for the
functions emulator and one for the
firestore
emulator in addition to that we can see
that we also now have a new function
deployed
called on user created we will go ahead
and create
an actual document in the users
collection and that function
should fire on its own which is why it's
called a reactive function
you can open up the firestore emulator
url
then you can click on start collection
we'll give it a collection id of users
and for the field value we know that we
are expecting an
email i'll be so kind to give you my
actual email address in case you have
any questions
which is dane at faultstacks.com
if i click save and that document is
created
when i open up the console there should
be
logs saying that we've sent an email to
this email address
it tells us that it begins the execution
and then it sends the email
and that's it you've created a reactive
function as well as an
http endpoint going further when you
want to expand your backend
you simply create a new file in the
dedicated folder
and it will be added automatically to
your backend when you deploy this one
last thing i wanted
to show you which is to improve the code
setup the way that the default
typescript project is set up is not
sufficient for consistent deployments
and debugging
and because of that we'll add some
additional things into our project we'll
start by making sure that the old
function code
doesn't lurk around when we're testing
any new changes
to fix that we'll add a new package into
the functions folder called
remraf we'll run npm install
d remraf this will install it as a
development
dependency then you can open up your
package.json file
and we'll add two new scripts into the
package.json
above the bold script we'll add a clean
script which we'll call
rimref and pass in the lib directory
and then we'll add our second script
which is called
pre-build and this will call the clean
script
the pre-build will always run before
build which pulls our typescript meaning
the old code will be deleted
before we build the new code and then to
deploy we can run
npm run build as you see there will now
be
three scripts that's being executed
because of the two additional ones we
added and then we'll run
npm run deploy this will only deploy the
functions to your backend
when the deployment is complete you'll
see your api link printed out
and we can do the exact same test with
postman that we did earlier
this is quite a new package and a way of
developing a back-end
on firebase for us but it provides a
clear path towards a
large and maintainable firebase product
if you want to see this being used in
development please check out my channel
where i'll be doing backend and
front-end work on a product over the
next
year thank you jeff for having me on
this awesome channel and thank you to
the contributors lou allen android that
helped me get the packages ready for
this tutorial
thank you guys for watching and i hope i
see you over at the full stacks channel
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one